I don't think artificial general
intelligence AGI is imminent but I think
it's possible the intelligence that we
have right now can't really reason can't
stick to facts it does what we call
hallucinations make stuff up all the
time real artificial intelligence or AGI
is not going to do that stuff it will
actually be able to reason you'll be
able to keep track of the world it won't
invent stuff arbitrarily that might be a
decade away it might be two decades away
I think it'll happen this Century but
we're not that close to it now even if
you had it we don't necessarily face
Extinction risk it doesn't follow like
night follows day that if you have a
smart machine that we're in Jeopardy
none of the machines that we've ever
built are particularly interested in
human territory for example you know go
has got machine go has gotten much
better but
the systems aren't fighting us for
territory things like that
um it doesn't go around killing all the
go players it doesn't go around killing
all the go players it doesn't even know
that there are go players right it just
knows about this board it's a real
speculation to say that machines are
ever going to have any interest uh in US
in that sense I wouldn't say it's
impossible Jeff Hinton said it's not
inconceivable and I think that's right
but I think what we should really be
worried about is what are Bad actors
going to do with these Technologies you
know we know we have bad humans that
want to seize territory enslave people
or whatever and so we should be watching
out for what people want to do with
these machines and not worrying so much
about like the Skynet scenario we should
have some people thinking about it I'm
not saying we should dismiss it all
together but I don't think it's our
immediate worry Kai Fu Lee came out with
a book a year or so ago maybe even more
now actually it's a few years old now ai
superpowers about China and the US
competing on AI he suggested that China
had a couple low structural advantages
in terms of access to more data because
it's kind of a top-down environment not
a lot of privacy
over there and so they could
crunch numbers at higher orders of
magnitude come up with better algorithms
and that was they also had support from
the government on a scale that the U.S
does not so those were two structural
advantages he cited for China there is
some anxiety that if
um one country or another develops uh
superiority in AI that this could be
worth hundreds of billions of dollars
which you're starting to see you're
starting to see some of the
repercussions in the stock market just
for fun because you've been in the space
for a long time did you buy Nvidia stock
a little while ago because I will say I
did not I did not I should have I've
been impressed with Jensen for a long
time and I should have
uh yeah I mean you'd have your sense of
what the heck is coming more so than
just about anyone
um but you're seeing something like
Nvidia get hundreds of billions of
dollars because now they're regarded as
the decor
chip manufacturer for uh developing AI
let me lay a stat on you and then I'll
come back to the kaifu stuff
um Microsoft just put out a stock
analysis I forget what we call it
um
the forecast they they predicted that uh
gpt4 and so forth large language models
would add about 10 billion dollars a
year to their revenue
and like that's a lot of money you know
to me or you but to them it's not
actually that much money the people
making the most money off the AI
Revolution right now are the chip
manufacturers are really one it's Jensen
uh at Nvidia
um making money off the dream that this
stuff is going to affect the world but
so far large language models although
they're extremely popular have not
actually led to that much material
Revenue people are using them to program
computers there's money in that but
there's not an enormous amount they're
using it for search engine optimization
there's a lot of experimenting but it's
not clear how much money there is in a
technology that's fundamentally
unreliable it's interesting JPMorgan has
banned consumer-facing use of chat Bots
Apple just did the same like some of the
big companies are waking up to the fact
that even though this AI has been really
hyped it doesn't necessarily work that
well so how much revenue there actually
comes is not clear and then link I'll go
back to the kaifuli
um
kaifu is certainly right that there is a
race on to get to AI or artificial
general intelligence I don't think we're
actually that close there's a lot of
worry over here that if we um you know
allow China to get to GPT 5 before us
that somehow the world will change in
radical ways that I think is silly you
know gbt5 will be better than gpt4 it
will write better boilerplate text but
it's not going to invent Interstellar
travel or you know redefine reality in
some fundamental way if China did get to
gpt5 six months before the United States
it's not clear it would have that much
consequence it probably raised their GDP
a little which they could kind of use
right now they're struggling a little
bit
um but it's not going to fundamentally
change science here's an example I give
gpt4
sees a lot of games of Chess in its
database it sees the rules of Chess and
it still does things like have Bishops
jump over Rooks like it does not
understand chess if you want to have a
system doesn't understand chess now
design a spaceship for you good luck
it's not really going to work like
people are attributing a kind of general
intelligence to these systems that they
don't really have so somebody may
eventually win the race to AGI but
nobody is close so it's not the
immediate concern that I think a lot of
people in both Nations think that it is
and you know there are now battles over
chips and and Export controls and stuff
like that I think partly premised on the
idea that gpt5 is going to be this
magical thing it's not really I wrote
this um essay called What to Expect When
You're Expecting gpt4 around Christmas
before GPT 4 came out and I said
people's minds are going to be blown but
as they dig in they're going to realize
that it's still flawed that it still
hallucinates that it still doesn't
understand in the world
Etc and all of these predictions I had
seven predictions they were all correct
and they boiled down in some ways saying
four will be better
but it's not going to be magic the way
the people initially think that it is
same thing's going to happen with five
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you